25 años después del final del conflicto
estos muros siguen en pie como símbolo
perdurable de las divisiones que siguen
asolando Irlanda del Norte
la gente pensaba que aquí se produciría
un momento como el del muro de Berlín en
cuanto a la eliminación de los muros que
las comunidades saldrían y cogerían
mazos y derribarían los muros y que
habría excavadoras eso nunca ha ocurrido
construidos En 1968 por el ejército
británico estos muros separaron durante
el conflicto a los republicanos
católicos prohielandeses de los
unionistas mayoritariamente protestantes
más de 3.500 personas murieron durante
tres décadas de derramamiento de sangre
organizaciones paramilitares como el ira
el ejército republicano Irlandés que
luchaban contra El dominio británico
llevaron a cabo campañas de atentados
con bombas y tiroteos los soldados
británicos hicieron redadas y registros
y dispararon contra los manifestantes
el acuerdo de viernes santo del 10 de
Abril de 1998 puso fin a la violencia
sectaria e inauguró un nuevo comienzo
para Irlanda del Norte se desmantelaron
los grupos paramilitares republicanos
las tropas británicas se retiraron y se
creó un nuevo gobierno regional en el
que estaban representados tanto los
nacionalistas como los unionistas fue un
compromiso honorable que contenía retos
para todos pero no disminuyó ninguna de
las opiniones políticas profundamente
arraigadas de los presentes tampoco
significaba que el futuro fuera a ser
fácil pero fue un nuevo comienzo sin
embargo las disputas políticas y los
estancamientos se convirtieron en rutina
tras el acuerdo agravados por la salida
del Reino Unido de la Unión Europea el
partido unionista democrático lleva 14
meses boicoteando al gobierno y a la
asamblea por su oposición a un acuerdo
comercial post brexit en El Aniversario
Del acuerdo de paz el Primer Ministro
Richie sanak hizo un llamamiento a los
políticos locales para restaurar el
gobierno si bien es hora de reflexionar
sobre los sólidos progresos que hemos
hecho juntos también debemos volver a
comprometernos a redoblar nuestros
esfuerzos sobre la promesa hecha en 1998
y los acuerdos que siguieron
se reunirá el martes en belfast con el
presidente estadounidense Joe biden y
también pondrá en marcha una importante
Cumbre sobre inversiones en Irlanda del
Norte en septiembre